in this video I want to go over the DNA
double helix so just a little bit about
its structure and what holds it together
so the DNA double helix well double
comes from the idea that there are two
single-stranded DNA molecules that come
together and are held together in one
double strata DNA molecule that's called
the double helix specifically because
those two strands don't just line up
together they actually twist about each
other so they arrange themselves in an
anti parallel fashion and the reason why
this is possible is because the strands
themselves have a directionality they
have directionality and pull or polarity
so directionality or polarity and so
idea that they have a five prime end
and a three prime end so the two strands
that line up against each other one will
line up 503 prime and the other one will
line up with the basis complementary in
the opposite direction it'll run 5 prime
to 3 prime the other way so the way that
would look is that if we had one strand
here this red strand going five prime to
three prime down this way then the blue
strand would be going 5 prime to 3 prime
up the other way so that's the idea
behind it being anti parallel now the
backbone the backbone is specifically a
sugar oops
put a why a sugar phosphate backbone now
that backbone is of course these thick
lines here this thick red line and this
thick blue line I wrote here I asked is
the backbone charged the answer to that
question is yes it is charged well what
is it that gives the backbone the charge
first of all it's negatively charged
okay and that negative charge comes from
the phosphate groups right the phosphate
groups have negative charges so along
this backbone we have a bunch of
negative charges here and I can go
through and
and you know write them all out these
are all negative charges that I'm
drawing here so I mean I can go on
forever but that's the purple idea that
this is this backbone is made up of
sugar and phosphates the the deoxyribose
sugar and the phosphate groups those
phosphate groups have negative charges
on them so DNA overall is a charged
molecule now the interior here that's
the nitrogenous bases now are those
nitrogenous bases charge is the interior
charge answer that question is now those
bases are not charged
okay now this helix that it's often
called a right-handed helix may actually
keep that in blue I don't want to change
the theme of the colors so here this is
a right-handed helix and what does that
really mean
it if you were to look down upon this
strand from the top here if you're
looking down at of your eyes if you
followed one strand that strand would
move clockwise okay so understanding
that portion I don't think is all too
important but if you as long as you
remember that the DNA double helix is a
right-handed helix that would probably
be good for any classes that you might
be taking another thing I do want to
mention is that the the DNA that exists
in vivo in life is a B DNA so in vivo
which is in life is the B DNA there are
other forms of DNA right including a a
DNA and z DNA but they're not the the
natural occurring DNA's so what holds
these two strands together so you'll
notice I've drawn I've drawn these
little dots in between it I'll explain
what that is in just a second but I
wrote here how are these these bases
held together because those if these
bases on one strand right are
interacting with the bases on the other
strand they're held together primarily
by hydrogen bonds okay so H bonds
okay so these H bonds between the base
pairs hold are the primary sort of force
that hold these these individual single
strands together in this double-stranded
DNA now between each a T pair there are
two hydrogen bonds and between the CG
pairs there are three hydrogen bonds so
I've ever presented that here I didn't
actually write out the letters but I
wrote here that some of these each of
these dots represents the hydrogen bonds
so two dots means two hydrogen bonds
three dots means three hydrogen bonds so
this would be an 80 pair and this here
would be a CG pair the way I remember
that is this sort of silly way I think
this see G stands for crazy guy he wants
all the H bonds comic relief from
studying I'm sure or you think I'm crazy
I'm afraid guy anyway the point is that
the 80 pairs have two H bonds that hold
them together the CG pairs have three h
bonds that hold them together however
you remember that it's up to you but
this is how I remember and you probably
won't forget how silly that was okay
there are some other things though that
hold these two strands of DNA together
the one key idea is this idea of
separation of hydro philic regions and
anhydrous and hydrophobic regions so
philic regions include the backbone the
backbone is is you know has these
negative charges sugar phosphate
backbone it is hydrophilic whereas the
interior these nitrogenous bases are not
so hydrophilic they're more hydrophobic
and this is of course all relatively
speaking right how'd you like dissolves
like so the hydrophilic portions will
want to stay together in the hydrophobic
portions will want to stay together so
the separation the fact that they're
separated in this way that the backbone
consists of the hydrophilic portion and
the interior is the hydrophobic portion
that helps stabilize the helix in
addition there are there are hydrophobic
interactions oops
hydrophobic interactions between the
bases themselves so not only are these
bases held together by these H bonds
here they're also held together by by
interact to the fact that this does say
this base pair right is right next to
this one the interactions here and here
those are hydrophobic interactions
holding together and you can imagine
that just this hydrophobic interaction
or just this hydrophobic interaction
going on here is not very powerful but
if you think about a really really long
strand really a bunch of base pairs all
these different interactions here
holding this together you can imagine
that this is overall pretty stable so I
hope that video was helpful in a sort of
overview about the double helix at the
DNA may be a little bit more insight to
what you've already known like I said I
hope that was helpful one last thing I
am a tutor if you live in Southern
California feel free to contact me via
email I love University at gmail.com and
see the description below for more
details thanks for watching